the question is
next year yeah what's it going to be
yeah what do we do and we're still we're
gonna do this again oh yeah next year
that's demanded I'm not drinking next
year what yeah yes you are why can't we
all just like taking out a bowl that'll
be fun okay we could do that I say we
take an edible or mushrooms and go to
Vegas okay oh that sounds like I hate it
I have never I love it I don't do
Edibles or mushrooms oh Square well I
mean tell me about mushrooms what would
that be a good experience for me I
honestly don't know I don't know I've
never done them
I bought them once but couldn't carve
out enough time to do them so I've I've
never done them I've micro dosing it
just made me nauseous yeah yeah okay
some people get that but I'll do it all
we could do
is Molly illegal
how about heroin
right we can do over-the-counter heroin
yeah you know what I love when Sona said
I bought these drugs but I didn't carve
out the time I thought I love a um a
drug addict who's just a poor planner
and so busy yeah and it's just like you
know hey did you get the stuff I did I
got the stuff I got the hair I got the
black tar heroin yeah did you get the
spoon oh and I really I had this
taxes to do I can't fit this in no and
then I gotta get the kids to the pool
promise and then I promise I get the
accurate of the mechanics yeah no I
still don't know what that knocking
sound is
yeah but what about the stuff huh oh uh
we'll get to that later can we just do
it later yeah let's table it yeah did
you get the rubber thing that ties off
the no no no no I figured we'd have that
around the house look we can't do this
now my mother-in-law's here in half an
hour
did you fix the hole in the beanbag
chair no
um all right well listen I had a good
time I do enjoy you guys and I do want
to say uh thank you uh to Matt because
you did a lot of the work so you made a
great drink oh I just your lovely wife
helped out yeah Sarah and Amanda and all
Sarah was a big help there's a whole
crew of people our crew is the best crew
I mean a lot of people deserve a shout
out Eduardo you were there Mikey Josh
for uh shooting the video chills yeah
when the solo stove guys
right I know we don't even have to
mention it because it's not required but
those solo stove uh the people that
brought that pizza oven
they did an amazing job yes and they
were very nice too I want my I want my
pizza DG and Chris is there still a solo
stove here for me to take home no that
one stays at the building you have to go
out and buy your own no I was promised
to solo stuff that's the only reason I
did this no no you thought you were
promised to solo stove I did what I told
you was have another drink oh okay
you just interpreter again
all right we'll see you guys next time
hope you're enjoying your summer
he's like
like when people sign yearbooks have a
good summer okay
you're enjoying your summer
hope you're enjoying your Summer with
the world the state it's in that's what
that's what I want it to sound like hey
hope you're having a good time
Canada's on fire enjoy your summer
I gotta go rob a bank